he's one of the most talented mma
fighters the arab world has ever
produced
nicknamed the jordanian lion jarrah
al-salawi is hungry for global success
after proving himself at regional level
the 29 year old welterweight steps into
the octagon in atlanta next month
looking for a third straight win in the
professional fighters league
god willing i would represent my people
the arab world and my country the best i
can i have great confidence that i will
be a champion i want to show that arab
fighters can compete and beat any
fighter in the world
salawi's recent fights have been in the
united states but right here in the
middle east where mma is growing in
popularity the jordanian fighter's
efforts are not going unnoticed
this is qatar mma one of an increasing
number of mixed martial arts gyms in the
region
however very few arabs compete at an
elite level so the rise of the likes of
salawi is giving aspiring fighters hope
if i were to see an arab doing well that
would inspire me to also pursue the
sport because it shows that people with
similar backgrounds to me can also be
successful in the sport that we're all
passionate about
salawi success could boost the
professional fighters league's plan to
expand in the middle east which is fast
becoming a hub for combat sports
[Music]
the four-year-old promotion is looking
to rival the ultimate fighting
championship or ufc which in 2019 signed
a five-year deal to stage bouts and
united arab emirates
saudi arabia has also hosted major
boxing matches
and regularly stages wwe wrestling
events
middle east uh is a critically important
um
piece of our global expansion jarrah is
an exciting fighter and we we believe he
has that star potential overall it is
important to create that affinity
uh with the middle east
leading with one of their their top
salawi hopes to inspire the arab mma
stars of tomorrow but he knows the best
way to do that is to keep on winning
suhail malik al jazeera doha